ils étaient moins nombreux la moitié
moins selon les différentes estimations
mais pour cet acte 2 de la contestation
les grévistes n'étaient pas moins en
colère et opposés à la réforme des
régimes de retraites prévue par le
gouvernement
travailler plus longtemps pour gagner
moins voilà ce que la rue anticipe des
changements à venir
il n'en est pas question clé rensing les
gens sont pas là pour travailler pendant
des années rien à voir derrière alors un
système un peu à l'américaine où il ya
des gens à 80 ans qui se remette à
travailler
moi j'ai pas envie que ça en france
encore aujourd'hui beaucoup de gilets
jaunes se sont mêlés aux groupes
syndicaux ajoutant de leurs voix toute
une liste de récriminations qui vont
bien au delà de la retraite à la chorale
des mécontents il y en a qui voudra
faire grève mais agnès berger foule le
pavé toutes les semaines depuis un an
macron c'est la mort peut-on résumer de
la pancarte qu'elle brandit on lâchera
rien on le rachat rien parce qu'on a
atteint un paroxysme
et donc voilà il est pire que le chaos
donc on peut comparer un lâcher parce
que c'est notre vie le premier ministre
edouard philippe dit ne pas vouloir être
dans la confrontation il est ouvert dit
il à ce que la réforme des retraites
soit appliquée de façon progressive
mais le président emmanuel macron qui
est la cible de bien des manifestants
aujourd'hui insiste la réforme des
retraites était essentielle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on veut en veut encore sur le dos faire
des économies
ça serait encore à nous travailleurs des
gens qui n'avons pas grand chose à la
fin du mois ça sera encore à nous de
faire un effort supplémentaire alors
qu'on en fait déjà régulièrement
moins de 24 heures avant de lever le
voile sur les détails de son plan de
réforme le gouvernement français mesures
est encore en soirée les aménagements
possibles pour calmer les grévistes mais
quelques augmentations de salaire ici et
reports d'entrer en vigueur l'un
n'empêcheront pas la grève douce
poursuivre il faut mettre en place sur
le premier ministre edouard philippe le
sait il aura bien du mal à se faire
entendre de ceux qui ne croient ni les
coffres à sec ni la réforme inévitable
il se marie ève bédard radio-canada
paris